In this lesson, we will look at
how data center tarffic engineering through customized
topologies and special mechanisms for load balance
can help reduce linkulization, reduce the number of
hops to each the edge of the data center, and make the data center network
easier to maintain. We saw in the
last lesson how existing data center topologies provide
extremely limited server to server capacity
because of the over subscription of the
links at the top of the hierarchy.
Additionally, as services continue to be migrated
to different parts of the data
center resources can be fragmented, significantly lowering
utilization. For example, if the service denoted
by green is running mostly in one
part of the data center, but there's a
little bit running on a virtual machine in
another part of the data center, this might
cause traffic to traverse. Links of the data
center topology hierarchy, thus significantly lowering utilization and
cost efficiency, reducing this kind of fragmentation can
result in complicated layer two, or layer three,
routing reconfiguration, what we'd like to have is
just the abstraction is of one large layer to switch, this is the abstraction
that VL2 provides. So, VL2 has two main objectives. One is to achieve
layer-two semantics across the entire data center
topology. This is done with a name-location
separation and a resolution service that resembles
the fabric manager which we talked about
in the last lesson. In which is described in more detail in the
paper. To achieve uniform high capacity
between the servers and balance load across
links in topology, VL2 relies on
flow based random traffic interaction using valiant
load balancing. Let's take a closer look at how that load balancing works.